[AUDIO LOGO]
INSTRUCTOR: Apologies.
I do have COVID
right now, which is
why I can't join you in person.
And so I am
congested, and I will
try not to cough into the mic.
And I'll speak slowly
and as loudly as I can.
So I wanted to show you or
talk about the breadth of what
Connect can do and
support because it
is getting quite complex.
And that's one of my favorite
things to do at conference
is talk about what you're
doing with Connect,
what workflows
you're building out,
what things you're creating.
And this diagram
just represents some
of what those things could be.
But interacting with Connect
should be quite simple.
It shouldn't be complex.
Essentially, what
you're doing is creating
something in R or Python.
You're publishing
that thing to Connect,
and then you're letting
Connect take over it,
executing that thing
for you and whoever
else you share that thing
with, this is it on Connect.
Under the hood,
Connect allows you
to do some really cool stuff.
You can run multiple
versions of R and Python.
You can now run multiple
versions of Quarto as well
on the single server.
And your applications,
your documents, your APIs,
everything that you create
and publish to Connect--
all of those things
are sandboxed apart
from one another
so that you can run
those different
versions of packages
for all of your content.
Fundamentally, though, if
you're using Connect today,
all of the content you
publish there, all of it
runs using these local processes
on the same host or container
as the Connect server.
And that's what I want
to draw your attention
to because this talk is what
comes next for Connect here.
It's about our next evolution
for content execution
and our story there.
So today we're really excited
to announce Off-Host Content
Execution for Connect
on Kubernetes.
This feature will
be in beta for now.
But if you are a
Connect admin, we
would love for you
to give it a trial.
What beta means?
In a bit, let's talk about
what this means for you.
So in this world, when you're
running Off-Host Content
Execution, now instead of
using local processes to run
all of your content items in
the same place as the Connect
server, Kubernetes is used
to execute your content.
And all of your jobs are
external to the container
that's running that
Connect server.
So I want to pause
here and make sure
that if you are a data
scientist or a Connect
publisher in the
audience today, you
should know that I am not
here to tell you that you need
to run home and learn how to
containerize your applications
or teach yourself Kubernetes.
Our goal is not to take away the
simplicity of that publishing
user experience like I
talked about at the beginning
of the presentation.
In fact, the publishing
user experience
should not change remarkably
so if you are running
Off-Host Content Execution.
So instead of telling
you, let me show you
what that looks like.
If you come over here to
the Documentation page
in the Connect
dashboard, and you
scroll down to where you used
to see all of the versions of R,
Python, Quarto that are
available on your server,
if you're running
off-host executions,
you'll now see a list or
a set of execution images.
And these are going to
show you the options
that you have as a
publisher for what
sorts of environments that can
be used to build and execute
your content.
You can choose to target a
specific one of these images
if you're publishing, or you
can let Connect just pick for you.
It has a version
mapping algorithm,
just like it picks for you
when you do publishing today.
Can you still hear me?
I guess, nobody's
there to respond.
Never mind.
I'll keep going.
STUDENT: We can.
Sorry.
INSTRUCTOR: OK, great.
Thank you.
All right.
So I'm going to
run through a quick
get back publishing
demo here just
to show you what this looks
like from the user experience
perspective.
And Git pop
publishing, in addition
to all of the other
publishing methods,
this really shouldn't
change very much.
So I'm going to grab a
URL here, drop it in.
This is my repo.
I'm going to select a branch.
And then select the
application in my repo
that I want, give
it a title, App 1.
And when I hit deploy, again,
because I haven't specifically
told Connect which
execution image
that I want to use to build and
execute this piece of content,
it's just going to find
one that runs R 4.1 for me.
So when I open it
up here, I will
be able to see a content item.
And it will use that
same execution image.
Now, you will notice
a little bit of delay
here when you launch an
application in Off-Host
Execution mode.
And some of that has to do maybe
sometimes with pulling down
that execution image.
But a lot of the
cost is wrapped up
in job spawning and
process startup.
So there is a little
bit more of a delay.
But again, if you wanted
to work around that,
you have the same tools as
you do with local execution
where you can set the
minimum processes.
You want to have
one always available
if this is a particularly
important app that
needs to come up very
quickly for your users.
Now let's see which
content execution image
Connect actually picked for me.
And I'll jump up
here so you can see.
Scroll down.
You'll see you have a
new piece of metadata
here at the bottom of
the Content Info pane.
And this just lists
the image that got
used for our last execution.
If I wasn't intending
to target that image,
then I would need to go back
and regenerate the manifest file
and specify a new
image parameter.
And this is all described
in the User Guide here.
So you can see how you can
add the image that you're
looking for specifically, if
you are generating a manifest.
But you can also use the
deployApp, deployAPI,
deployDoc, deploySite
functions from RS Connect.
And similar functions exist
for RS Connect Python as well.
If there isn't an image that
matches the version of R
or Python that you need,
you'll get the same type
of deployment error
as you would today
using local execution
with local processes
if there isn't a version of
R or Python on your server
that's available.
All right.
So hopefully, that
has reasonably
convinced you that the
user experience isn't
going to change remarkably,
although you can now target
images if you want to do that.
We don't yet have support
for push-button publishing
for targeting specific images,
but that is on our roadmap.
So look out for that
if you're interested.
All right.
So now that I've
gone through that,
I want to switch gears
and talk more directly
to maybe the Administrator
persona about what
this looks like.
Let's talk about off-host
execution from that angle.
Now, if you are an
admin, you should
know that this functionality
uses the same components
if you're familiar with
the RStudio Workbench
product and its new
Job Launcher component.
We're using that same paradigm
but bundling it with that.
So if you want to run off-host
execution with Connect,
you're going to need to use
a version of Connect that
has the Job Launcher
bundled with it.
So recommend starting with
the latest release of Connect,
which is our July edition
that went out last week.
In addition to that, you're
going to need to have,
as always, a valid Connect
license and then database.
And that will be
Postgres for this case.
And then some shared
file storage--
could be NFS, or EFS,
anything that's ReadWriteMany.
On the Kubernetes requirement
side, you're going to need,
of course, a working
Kubernetes cluster.
You're going to need the
Kubernetes command line tool,
and also Helm version 3,
which is the package manager
for Kubernetes in this case.
If you have all of those
things, you're basically
set up to go at this point.
And we have
documentation for how
to run through, install,
and configure to get
all the way to this point.
But I've showed a lot
of architecture diagrams
at this point, and
they're not the best way
to illustrate all of this.
So because I'm remote and
nobody is here to stop me,
I thought it would be cool
just to do a speed run
installation of all of this,
see how far we can get,
and show you just how fast
and easy it is to get up
and running.
Hopefully, that will
be what happens.
It will be fast and easy.
I have cheated a little, as
always, as any good speed
installation does.
I've already set up my
Kubernetes Cluster--
get nodes where they are.
They're ready to go.
And I've already set some
environment variables.
I set up my RStudio
Connect license key
so that you can't see my key.
And then I've also created
a database password
for my Postgres database.
I have the Kubernetes
tool kubectl--
whatever it's called
there-- installed.
And that's all set up.
And in this next
section, we will Helm
install all the things.
This is really just
a box subtitled,
"A love letter to Helm."
And Helm is really
awesome, and we're
excited to be able to
install everything this way
because it makes the
installation so simple.
It makes it repeatable.
You can update.
You can roll back and
stage your deployment.
And I'll show you what some
of that looks like here.
Clear.
And the first
thing we need to do
is pull down a
bunch of Helm charts
in order to do that and
update the Helm repo.
So we provide a chart for
installing RStudio Connect
here.
I'm going to grab
that in addition
to the one for Postgres and NFS.
We'll update the repo.
The Postgres and NFS
charts are just sort of
for illustrative purposes.
We're assuming
that most folks are
going to bring
their own Postgres,
and NFS, or EFS
ReadWriteMany shared storage.
But if you didn't have
anything like that
or if you're doing the same
sort of speed installation
that I'm doing here,
you can use these to get
up and running really fast.
All right, so we've got
all our charts good to go.
And the next thing
we're going to do
is create a namespace to
install everything I do.
And this will just keep
everything nice a sandboxed,
neat and tidy.
And going to call this work
namespace RStudio Connect.
And once we have that
and we switched into it,
we can now start Helm
installing things.
So the first one, I'll helm
--install my Postgres chart.
I'm actually using this Helm
Upgrade --install command,
which I just learned
a couple of weeks ago,
which is really cool
because you can just
run the same thing over and
over again, and upgrades it
if it already exists.
It installs it if it doesn't.
I'm going to do the same with
my NFS server provisional chart.
Run that.
All right.
Now if I've done
everything correct,
I should be able
to get some pods.
Awesome.
So I've got my NFS creating.
My Postgres is running,
and I'm good to go.
Let's make sure that comes up.
Cool.
All right.
Now we're on to the
Connect installation.
This is the meat of it here.
So if you wanted to look at
all of the default values that
come with the RStudio
Connect Helm chart,
you can do a helm show
values on the Connect chart.
And that will just give
you the whole list.
There's quite a lot.
I'm going to go
ahead and skip that.
What we're going to do is
overwrite some of those default
values with values.yaml file.
So let's create that--
New File.
And this first part is
going to set the replicas,
and then I'm going to
configure shared storage here.
So I'm going to grab all that.
So back in, Connect
needs shared storage.
Needs to be mounted in.
You need to create a Persistent
Volume Claim and give it a name
here.
And this name is arbitrary
that's used in a couple places
here.
So make sure if you
change that, that you
change it all the places
that it needs to be changed.
You're going to create
a storage class for NFS,
tell it how much storage
you're requesting.
And then finally,
enable the launcher.
And that's all there is to it.
So if I Save out here and
name it values.yaml, Save.
All right.
Now I am good to go.
And from here, your
process for using Helm
is to change this
values.yaml file
and then run this command
here, helm template, the chart
with your values.yaml.
And this sort of pattern,
updating your values.yaml
and then checking
it on helm template,
will show you how your values
file affects the template.
And that's what my buddy Cole
and Helm wizard calls the bread
and butter of using Helm.
This is the power.
And it's also going to be
really useful as we interact
with you because you can send
us your values.yaml file,
and then we at RStudio
on the Support side
can run this same
helm template command
and see exactly
what you're saying.
We can see how your
values.yaml file is going
to interact with the template.
So that's really useful.
The other section
that we're going
to want to add to
this values.yaml file
is some configuration
for Connect itself.
So this is where the things
that you would traditionally
put in your go
configuration file
are going to get dumped instead.
So let's add that.
And you'll see that we
are adding a database
configuration.
We're saying it's
going to be Postgres,
and that will overwrite
the default of SQLite.
And then give it an address.
Again, if you're using
the Connect namespace,
the RStudio-Connect namespace,
that URL should be correct.
And then you're just
going to provide
the same persistent
volume claim name
for this new section
of configuration
for Connect Launcher.
And that should match
what you had up here.
So let's save that out.
And now if I did
everything correct,
we should be able to
helm install Connect.
Let's give it a shot.
Installing it now.
Get pods.
PERSON: Kelly?
INSTRUCTOR: It's creating.
Yes?
PERSON: You're just out
of time, unfortunately.
[LAUGHS]
INSTRUCTOR: Oh, sorry.
OK.
Thank you.
PERSON: Yeah, if you can
wrap up in 30 seconds
if you have the final
thought as we switch over.
There's a couple of questions
I saw folks asked on Slido.
Please ask those at
the Open-Source lounge.
And let's give Kelly
a hand for the talk.
INSTRUCTOR: Yeah, thanks.
I wanted to say thank you
to the team, for sure.
This project has come
together over a while
by a number of
folks at RStudio--
the core team as it is today.
I want to say
congratulations to Aron,
and Bill, Chaita, Chris,
Cole, David, and Jill.
And thank you to all of
the folks who helped us out
during the private beta
over the last year.
That's been really great.
So thank you.
[AUDIO LOGO]